all right we're on problem number eight
and they ask us which equation is
equivalent to
5x minus 2 times 7x plus 1 is equal to
14x so i'm guessing they just want to
simplify this a little bit and see if we
get to one of these choices so let's do
that so we start with 5x
minus 2 times 7
x plus 1 is equal to 14
x
and let's this this is i think the most
obvious thing to simplify this 2 times
the
seven x plus one or we could even say
minus two times seven x plus one so then
this becomes
five x plus i'm just gonna distribute
the minus two times all of this plus
minus two times seventeen x is
minus 14x
minus 14x and then minus 2 times 1 is
minus 2
is equal to 14x
and let's see on all of these choices
they have 14x on the right hand side so
they just want us to simplify this so
this simplifies to 5x
see plus minus 14 so that's minus 14x
minus 2 is equal to 14x so we have 5x
minus 14x what's 5 minus 14. it's it's
what minus 9 right
minus 9x
minus 2 is equal to 14
x
and that is choice a
and one thing that maybe i realized i
skipped a kind of skipped a step we
could have just
let me let me just do this just so that
you understand this step that i did here
we could have just said minus and then
distribute the 2. so we could have right
there said 5x minus
positive 2 times 7x 14x
plus 2 times 1
plus 2. i'm just doing the left hand
side and then we could have distributed
the minus sign so you get 5x
minus 14x
minus 2.
either way it would have gotten us to
this point
and then we could have simplified here
and gotten choice a
next problem
which equation is equivalent to okay so
another case where i'm guessing they
just want to simplify it want us to
simplify these these equations so let me
write that down
times 2 minus 5 x
is equal to six minus three
times one minus three x
all right let's distribute this four
first so you get four times two is eight
four times minus five x is minus twenty
x
minus 20x is equal to 6
minus
and i don't maybe you might have been
tempted to say oh 6 minus 3 and that's 3
and then distribute remember order of
operations multiplication comes first
right so we have to multiply the 3 times
the 1 minus 3x before we can deal with
the 6. as well on the other side there's
just the multiplication first
all right so here 3 times 1 minus 3x
so it'll be 3
i'm just going to do minus a positive 3
times e to the so 3 times a pot negative
3 is minus 9 x
and now i can distribute this minus sign
so let's see on the left hand side i
have
let me do it in a brighter color the
left hand side i have eight
minus 20x
is equal to six and then i'm gonna
subtract this whole thing so i can you
can view it as distributing a negative
one times both of these so six
plus minus 3 or just 6 minus 3 and then
a minus times a minus plus 9x
plus 9x all right now let's see what we
could do to help simplify this what
happens if we add 20x to both sides then
the left-hand side it goes away so we're
just left with 8 is equal to
well let me just simplify well let me
just do that 6
minus 3 i added 20x so plus 29x
i really should have simplified this 6
minus 3 but i didn't want to do too much
in one step so
8 is equal to 3 plus 29 x
and then if we subtract 3 from both
sides
here we get 8 minus 3 is 5 that 3 goes
away and you get 29x
and that is choice c
29x is equal to 5.
c
next question problem number 10
and i should be careful that you don't
think that all of this stuff is for this
problem
the total cost c in dollars of renting a
sale boat for n days is given by this
equation
okay
if the total cost was 360 dollars for
how many days was the sailboat rented so
they're giving us c c is 360
so they're telling us that 360
that's the total cost and that's going
to be equal to 120
plus 60 times the the total days rented
times 60 n and that's what they want us
to figure out and how many days was the
sailboat sale boat rented
let's see if you subtract 120 from both
sides of this equation you get
is equal to 60n
i'll go here and if you divide both
sides of this by 60 240 divided by 60
that's the same thing as 24 divided by 6
so that's 4
and then 60 n divided by 60 is of course
one so that is n so the sailboat was
rented for four days
all right problem
number eleven
okay and i i cut and pasted part of it
but they want us to know they want us to
determine what was the first incorrect
step that they did in this problem so
let's see if we can determine that so
let's see solve 3 times x plus 5 is
equal to 2x plus 35 fair enough so in
this first step they distributed 3 times
x
3 times 5 right 3x plus 15 is equal to
2x plus 35 so step 1 looks good to me
let me do that in a darker color step 1
looks good they distributed the 3.
now let's see what they do it did in
step 2
let's see if i wanted to solve this i
would subtract 2x from both sides and it
looks like that's what they attempted to
do because they got rid of this 2x right
on the right hand side they went from 2x
plus 35 to just 35 so somehow they got
rid of this 2x and the only way to get
rid of it is to subtract 2x from both
sides
right subtract 2x from both sides
now if i subtract 2x from both sides
sure enough the right hand side will
just be left with the 35
the let the left hand side will have the
15 of course and then i have minus 2x
plus 3x
well minus 2x plus 3x that's x so this
5x shouldn't that shouldn't be there it
should be x
plus 15 is equal to 35. so even though
they were trying to
get rid of this 2x and they should have
subtracted 2x from both sides they
inadvertently added 2x here so they said
2x plus 3x is equal to 5x well that was
wrong you have to subtract and you're
just left with x plus 15 is equal to 35.
so step 2 is when they made their first
error
problem 120
120 foot long rope is cut into three
pieces
the first piece of the rope let me draw
this is
begging for a diagram
all right so they say
the first piece of rope is twice as long
as the second piece of rope
okay and then they say the third piece
of rope is three times as long as the
second piece of rope okay everything is
a multiple of the second piece of rope
all right let me
so the second one was the shortest one
just reading it right the first is twice
as long as the second the third is three
times as long so this is
so if i just drew it
so if this is the second length of rope
let's call that x
right that's the second length of rope
and they told us
the first piece of rope the first
piece of rope is twice as long as the
second piece of rope okay so this is the
first piece of rope right here it's
going to be twice as long as the second
piece of rope so that's 2x
fair enough and then they tell us i'll
do some magenta
the third piece of rope is three times
as long as the second piece of rope so
this is the third piece of rope here is
three times as long as the second piece
of rope so it's 3x
and they say what is the length
of the longest piece of rope
all right so let's think about it
if i add up all of these segments right
what do they add up to well they tell us
that it's a 120 foot long rope
so let me add that up so i if i do 2x
plus x
plus 3x that's going to equal 120 feet
that is equal to 120 feet right that
whole distance
is 120.
so 2x plus x is 3x plus three s you get
six x
is equal to one hundred and twenty you
divide both sides by six
you get x as you see 120 divided by six
is twenty
all right that's what x is that's the
second long that's the second piece of
rope or the shortest piece of rope
because that's they tell us that the
other ones are some multiple of that
length but they want to know what is the
length of the longest piece of rope the
longest piece of rope well the longest
piece of rope is clearly piece three
right is three times the second piece
piece one was only two times so this is
what they want to know they want to know
what 3x is equal to
so 3x is equal to 3 times 20
which is equal to 60 feet
and that's choice c
next problem
see if i have time
yeah i think i have time
i might as well attempt to fit it in
all right
don't want to rush them though
let's see
where the cost to rent a construction
crane is 750 per day plus two hundred
fifty dollars per hour of use
what is the maximum number of hours the
crane can be used each day
each day if the rental cost is not to
exceed
to twenty five hundred 500
per day okay so how much is the cost per
day
so the cost per day
is equal to
750 so no matter how little or much we
use it we have to pay that 750 dollars
per day so it's equal to seven hundred
and fifty dollars
plus 250 per hour so plus
times the number of hours this is how
what our total cost is per day
and they want to say
what is the max what is the maximum
number of hours the crane can be used
each day if the rental cost is not to
exceed twenty five hundred dollars per
day so this whole thing has to be less
than or equal to twenty five hundred
dollars right the total cost has to be
less than or equal to twenty five
hundred dollars so now let's just solve
this equation right there
and i'll do it up here so we know that
plus 250 let me do it down here actually
more space
so it's the first thing we could do here
we could subtract 750 from both sides of
this equation so we get
times h
is less than or equal to
2500 minus 750 that's what 1750
right yeah because 1500 minus 750 is
750. right 1750 right i just subtracted
750 from both sides of this equation
let me write that down sometimes that i
want to make so i said minus 750
plus that and then i said minus 750
and of course minus 750 plus 750 that
goes to zero and that's why you don't
see anything over here and on the right
hand side 2500 minus 750 is 1750.
all right now let's just divide both
sides by 250. we don't have to do
anything to the inequality sign since
250 is a positive number
so the hours the maximum number of hours
the hours have to be less than or equal
to
over 250
which is let's see 1750 divided by 250
that's the same thing as 25
that's the same thing as 175 divided by
25 goes into 175 what is that
i want to say 7 times
7 7 times 5 is 35
7 times 2 is 14 plus 3 is 17 right
so
h has to be less than or equal to 7
hours and that is choice c
see in the next video